no
[Música]
ah
i
la primera mentira yo no soy leovigildo
galarza mi nombre es aquiles báez
leovigildo no pudo venir
bueno por todos los problemas de tráfico
incluso aéreo
yo no me explico como un paro termina
afectando hasta los aviones bueno y
empiezo mal porque les digo que me llamo
aquí les va esa y yo no me llamo aquiles
báez pero no les voy a decir como cómo
me llamo de verdad pero necesito que me
crean lo que les voy a decir entonces
ahora estoy arrancando con una mentira
y necesito que me crean entonces quiero
contarles algo de la historia de
actualidad panamericana y esos esas
cosas tan inesperadas que nos pasaron
[Música]
sin proponérnoslo entonces
primero un poquito de contexto esta es
una charla seria no tengan demasiadas
expectativas
esta es una charla
muy seria que comienza con antes del
internet antes del internet los medios
de comunicación la tenían bastante fácil
porque la credibilidad veraz y vertical
venía los dueños de los medios de
comunicación los que podían pagar como
imprimir un periódico
pues tenían ganada la credibilidad pero
luego llegó a internet y todos sabemos
qué pasó cuando llegó internet cualquier
persona puede crear un medio que le
compita a un medio comunicación grande o
tradicional y con las redes sociales
pues mucho peor cualquier persona
con talento puede puede
y llegar a tener un flujo de visitantes
similar a un medio tradicional
y qué pasó los medios se sostenían con
suscripciones y ahora se tenían que
sostener con publicidad y por eso vemos
tantos ejemplos de noticias
chimbas que publican los medios ahora
qué
que uno ya no sabe a quién creerle
perdieron su identidad
entonces ahora sí un poquito de la
historia actualidad panamericana y como
necesitamos que sea creíble se nos
ocurrió hacerla a punta de trinos este
trino es muy importante en la historia
de actualidad panamericana porque en
diciembre estábamos despachados
un grupo de amigos sin mucho que hacer
nos encontramos este trino del senador
juan carlos vélez que decía que el
primero de enero del 2014 hubo 37
muertos por sobredosis de marihuana en
colorado entonces nos fuimos para
colorado no mentiras de entonces
dijimos un momento eso es falso eso eso
no ha pasado todavía no existe el primer
caso de sobredosis de marihuana porque
un senador una persona preparada educada
con poder
se cree un cuento como estos pueden ver
la fecha de cetrino el 3 de enero como
estamos en vacaciones no teníamos nada
que hacer
cinco días después ya estaba actualidad
panamericana con esta noticia
una una noticia bastante tonta que dice
que por un el ladino de ron con pasos le
aplican la ley de conductores ebrios
yo fui de los últimos en entrar a
actualidad panamericana y me gusta
contar esto porque porque a mí de verdad
me emociono mucho haber entrado
actualidad panamericana yo lo que vi es
que todos mis amigos estaban
compartiendo noticias falsas mentirosas
y yo no sabía dónde había salido como
mucha gente que no sabía incluso medios
de comunicación empezaron a preguntarse
o hablar de esas noticias cuando uno
mi amigo leovigildo el que no pudo venir
me dijo oiga nosotros somos los que
estamos haciendo esto quiere quiere
participar pues claro siempre fue mi
sueño decir mentiras en una escala en
una escala
pues global y empezaron a pasar cosas
como no hay mucho tiempo no voy a pasar
muchos ejemplos pero empezaron a creerse
nuestras noticias que hacíamos con la
intención de mamar gallo o sea de
reírnos de burlarnos de pasarla chévere
empezaron a creérselo periodistas
políticos expresidentes cantantes
presentadores de televisión y desde
adentro nos dimos cuenta de que aquí
pasa algo o sea cuando cuando yo escribí
una noticia por ejemplo que decía aquí a
los colombianos que en la unión europea
les estaban pidiendo a los colombianos
dejar de pedir regalar las cosas yo
escribí esa noticia
al otro día puse la radio y escuché a
néstor morales hablando 15 minutos de
esa noticia como si fuera real
y yo la escribí y él decía que era que
eran fuentes de la cancillería las que
le habían dicho eso
[Aplausos]
bueno cayó un montón de gente pero esta
noticia no lanzó a la estratosfera
rodolfo llinás el cerebro más grande que
tiene colombia neurocientífico no había
podido entender cómo diablos era que
funcionaban las tarjetas con las que uno
se mueve en bogotá había tres tarjetas y
la verde servía para una cosa y la la
gracia y la roja para otra bueno
y pues resulta que él no fue el único
cerebro
el cerebro fugado que hablo de esto
porque el entonces
senador pacho santos
utilizo esa noticia para atacar al
alcalde de bogotá en ese momento que era
gustavo petro y eso sí fue noticias y
fue titular de todos los medios ya no
fueron conociendo y
muy importante los medios de
comunicación la competencia digamos
empezaron a
pero nuestros nuestros portales aliados
nos empezaron a reconocer y no y no nos
decían el medio de noticias falsas
actualidad panamericana eso es muy
importante porque nosotros no somos un
medio de noticias falsas somos un medio
satírico y que hace uno con la sátira
con la sátira es usar el humor al
servicio de una causa es de usar el
humor para decir algo para opinar cuando
yo entré actualidad- panamericana a mi
me preguntaban de pp pse empezamos a dar
algunas charlas ninguna es tan
importante como esta en serio
y no se empezaban a preguntar
lo que ustedes hacen es periodismo y
decía no no no no no no no
esto es mamá de regalo total pero con el
paso del tiempo empezamos a darnos
cuenta que lo que hacemos es periodismo
de opinión
y eso eso es muy importante entonces
digamos cuando facebook dijo que el
algoritmo iba a tumbar todas las páginas
de noticias falsas pues temblamos pero
eso nos ayudó a reforzar nuestra
identidad dijimos no nos no nos tumbaron
no somos un portal de noticias falsas
somos somos un medio satírico usamos
noticias mentirosas para para para
opinar y para o para otras cosas más
importantes entonces
si no traje ejemplos de las noticias
pues chistosas que hacemos pero traje
tres ejemplos que son muy importantes
para la res tres noticias pueden visitar
nuestro portal tenemos más de 2500
noticias que hemos hecho pero hay tres
ejemplos que para mí son muy importantes
está con los 91 mil millones de
publicidad de peñalosa el alcalde de
bogotá bogota ya tendría un disneyworld
esta noticia porque es importante porque
esas cifras no la tenían ningún otro
medio en ese momento es esa cifra es
real
porque para mí es tan importante eso
porque detrás de cada noticia falsa
nuestra hay una gran verdad siempre
siempre cualquier titular que vean
estamos tratando de decir algo que es
cierto y manejamos las cifras con rigor
este ejemplo es muy importante nosotros
necesitábamos hablar de los asesinatos
de los líderes sociales pero nadie le
estaba poniendo cuidado a ese tema
entonces dijimos como diablos hacemos
para que la gente voltea mirar esa cifra
pues desde el 2017 tristemente esa cifra
se ha multiplicado muchísimo entonces
titulamos que cada tres días sacrifican
un gatico y ya van 53 esta noticia tuvo
un buen tráfico digamos mucha gente la
consultó pero lo más importante es que
en el desarrollo de la noticia
hablábamos de
pues una metáfora de que estaban matando
gatitos constantemente iba creciendo la
cifra y nadie se explicaba quién lo
estaba haciendo y en el último párrafo
decíamos si usted llegó hasta aquí en
esta noticia le aclaramos que no estamos
hablando de gatitos estamos hablando de
personas pero si no hubiéramos puesto
gatitos en la foto usted no habría leído
esto
este es uno de los trinos de muchos de
gente que sé
se se movió con la noticia
y eso nos hace sentir muy orgullosos
porque no hay tema por difícil que sea
que no podamos tocar con humor y con
pues con algo de creatividad
y esta no es una noticia exactamente
esto es bueno es una noticia de otro
portal aliado de vanguardia
agosto el 2018 actualidad panamericana
desapareció
totalmente cerramos nuestra página para
mostrar es durante cuatro días creo y
eso se empezó a volver noticia los
medios empezaron a preguntarse qué pasó
los amenazaron se les acabó la plata que
les pasó
y regresamos el 30 de agosto con un
vídeo que decía nosotros regresamos pero
hay miles de desaparecidos que todavía
no aparecen
por el día internacional de los
desaparecidos
gracias y ese entonces se puede hablar
de cualquier tema
cómo lo hacemos
como lo hacemos para para ganar
credibilidad a punta de mentiras
entonces digamos este es un ejemplo de
con la coyuntura del ministro de defensa
hubiéramos podido haber hecho lo más
fácil que se había hablado de duke haber
hablado del centro democrático y todo
pero aprovechamos para echar una pedrada
hacia atrás
entonces hay rigor tenemos nuestra ética
en serio tenemos nuestra ética que es
que se reduce a una cosa es no
revictimizar no pegarle al débil y en
eso nos diferenciamos de otros medios
que hacen humor porque hace reír pues
hay muchas maneras de hacer reír hacer
bullying hacer reír
el humor que se burla de los defectos de
nosotros nos hace reír pero no es lo
nuestro nosotros queremos diferenciarnos
de eso
entonces tenemos rigor tenemos nuestro
nuestra ética
no nos gusta ser obvios porque siempre
nos pasa tenemos un consejo de redacción
que es un chat de whatsapp 24 horas
así funcionamos no tenemos oficinas no
tenemos greca agua cristal no tenemos
nada de eso
tenemos un chat y en el chat votamos
ideas y siempre descartamos la primera
idea y esa idea la vemos a la hora la
vemos en un meme que cualquier otra
persona publicó y eso nos hace nos hace
muy felices tratar de mantener cierto
nivel de calidad también hacemos otra
cosa y es tratar de mantener cierto
equilibrio le pegamos a petro un día
pero al otro día le pegamos a duke y eso
tiene
y eso tiene sus consecuencias este de
prótesis de las respuestas que recibimos
todos los días
este es un fan herido a alguien que nos
adora un día y nos pasa todo el tiempo
gente que son lo máximo son lo más
chéveres quiero ser como ustedes quiero
escribir para actualidad panamericana
hasta que le toque uno la fibra que no
debe entonces ahí dejamos de ser
chéveres
entonces se puede tener credit la
credibilidad a punta de mentiras pues yo
creo que sí y con frecuencia cada vez
más recibimos este tipo de respuestas
también el usa mucho la gente el hashtag
parece de actualidad panamericana o
actualidad panamericana se está quedando
sin trabajo en estas manifestaciones de
esta semana una persona salió con una
pancarta que decía eso actualidad
panamericana se está quedando sin
trabajo eso es muy emocionante ya pasar
como al mundo real
ya pues para para cerrar entonces la
respuesta es sí se puede ser creíble
apunta de mentiras pero hay que trabajar
en eso todos los días con mucha seriedad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]